Hallo. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen diese Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ist das verständlich? Ja, okay.
Wie heißen Sie? Mein Name ist Manfred Meier.
Könnten Sie langsam Buchstabieren, bitte?
Was soll ich Buchstabieren?
Damit ich besser schreibe.
Ihren Namen.
Ah, okay. Könnten Sie Ihren Namen oder Vornamen oder Namen?
Ja.
Was soll ich denn Buchstabieren?
Meine Vorname heißt Manfreds und wird geschrieben M-A-N-F-R-E-D.
Ja.
Und der Nachname Meier, Man-M-E-Y-E-R.
Ja. Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
60.
Wann sind Sie gerne geboren?
Am 1.07.1963.
1.07.1963.
63.
Alles klar.
Herr Meier, was führt Sie zu uns? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Folgendes. Ich bin heute Morgen beim Spazierengehen aufgerutscht.
Ich habe meine Rechte des Handgelenk gefallen.
Seitdem habe ich Schmerzen und es ist ein bisschen geschwollen.
Und kann mein Handgelenk nicht richtig bewegen.
Wegen dieser Verbindung, ich kann Sie nicht deutlich hören.
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Ja.
Ich bin heute Morgen beim Spazierengehen ausgerutscht.
Und auch meine Rechte des Handgelenk gefallen.
Ich habe mir mein Handgelenk verletzt. Es tut mir weh.
Ja.
Ich kann mein Handgelenk nicht richtig bewegen.
Es ist eingeschränkt.
Klar.
Und heute Morgen, sind Sie auf Ihr Kopf gefallen?
Nein, nur nach vorne auf mein Handgelenk gefallen.
Ich konnte mit meinen Hand so mich abstützen.
Aber seitdem tut mein Handgelenk weh.
Mein rechter Handrenntgelenk tut mir weh.
Was für ein Schmerz ist das?
Es tut mir weh.
Wie soll es beschreiben?
Es pocht wie ein Herz.
Haben Sie Schwellung bemerkt dort?
Ja, genau.
Was ist das?
Es ist Farbeanderung bemerkt.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Wärme.
Es ist total weh.
Es ist geschwollen.
Es hat sich nicht verändert.
Es ist nicht überwärmt.
Es ist geblutet.
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Meine Haut ist intakt.
Haben Sie sonstige Beschwerden?
Weitere Beschwerden habe ich nicht.
Zum Beispiel vor dem Sturz.
Hatten Sie Schmerz vor den Augen?
Schmerz vor den Augen?
Schwarz vor meinen Augen.
Hat es vor meinen Augen schwarz gewesen?
Nein, war es nicht.
Ich habe gesagt, ich bin ausgerutscht und gestürzt.
Da war nass gewesen.
Da war nass und blätter gewesen.
Da bin ich ausgerutscht.
War Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, war es nicht.
Vorher und nachher auch nicht.
Jetzt werde ich noch einige Fragen stellen.
Um ein umfassendes Bild.
Ihr kranken Geschichte zu haben.
Herr Meier.
Wie ist Ihr Stullgang?
Ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe meine Erreignisse bemerkt.
Ich habe meine Stullgang.
Ich habe die Erreignisse bemerkt.
Was hat es mit meinem Handgelenk zu tun?
Nachdem ich diese Erreignisse habe.
Warum fragen Sie so etwas?
Ich habe doch mein Handgelenk verletzt.
Stellen. Okay. Also ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang. Alles okay.
Oder haben Sie nach diesem Sturz erbrochen? Nein. War Ihnen übel? Nein, auch nicht.
Jetzt könnten Sie diese Schmerz aushalten oder brauchen Sie ein Schmerzmittel?
Wenn ich nicht viel bewege, so ruhig halte, dann kann ich das aushalten. Nur wenn ich bewegen möchte, dann kann ich es aushalten.
Aber im Ruhe, Sie haben keine Schmerzen, ne?
Im Ruhe habe ich Schmerzen, aber nicht so stark.
Ja, außer dieser Stuhlereignis. Wie ist Schlaf? Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Nein. Wenn ich heute nichts gemacht habe, dann habe ich heute Nacht Schlafstörungen wegen meinen Schmerzen. Ansonsten nicht.
Waren Sie schlaflos durch diesen Fall? Noch nicht. Das war ja heute Morgen passiert. Heute Morgen.
Aber wenn heute nichts gemacht wird, heute Nacht wird wahrscheinlich ein Problem sein.
Ja, gestern Nacht oder? Gestern Nacht hatte ich keine Probleme.
Ja, alles gut.
Und gibt es in Ihren Vorgeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Oder leiden Sie unter chronische Krankheiten?
Was meinen Sie unter chronische Krankheiten? Ich weiß nicht, was chronisch oder ich bin kein Mediziner.
Haben Sie irgendwelche wichtige Krankheiten? Zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit, erhöhte Bluthochdruck?
Ja, genau, erhöhte Bluthochdruck, das habe ich. Ich bin kein Mediziner, ich verstehe, die einige, die wir vernichten.
Ja, kein Problem, ich verstehe. Seit wann haben Sie erhöhte Bluthochdruck?
Seit sieben Jahren.
Nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente?
Ja, nur einen Medikament nehme ich ein.
Wissen Sie den Namen?
Ja, ACE-Hemmer, 10 Milligramm, dann nehme ich morgens immer einen ein, damit es beim Blutdruck gut eingestellt.
Einmal morgens und einmal abends?
Nur morgens.
Nur erhöhte Blutdruck? Ansonsten wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, in meiner Jugend, wo ich 17 Jahre alt war, wurde ich an meinem Blindam operiert.
Blindam, was passiert? Entfernt Blindam?
Genau, Blindam wurde entfernt.
Wissen Sie, war es komplikationslos?
Ja, alles war normal gut gelaufen, ich hatte keine Probleme danach.
Haben Sie sonstige Medikamente?
Nein, nur diese Medikamente.
Rauchen Sie, Hammer?
Ja, eine halbe Packung, pro Tag rauche ich schon.
Halbe Packung, seit wann, brauchen Sie?
Oh je, bestimmt seit 40 Jahren.
40 Jahren?
Ja.
Das ist aber zu viel, ne?
Ja, sagt meine Frau auch immer.
Und meine Freundin, leider kann ich das nicht loswerden, habe ich öfters versucht.
Wenn Sie möchten, könnten Sie mit Sozialberatung über Rauchen kommunizieren,
damit Sie vielleicht mit dem Rauchen aufhören, wenn Sie möchten.
Kann ich es irgendwann mal versuchen, ja?
Jetzt muss ich mal meinen Handgelenk erlösen.
Mein Problem mit meinem Handgelenk.
Trinken Sie Alkohol oder Schnaps?
Schnaps Alkohol.
Ja, also regelmäßig trinke ich nicht, aber bei Geselligkeit, bei Feiern,
trinke ich schon mal eine Flasche Bier.
Das ist eine rotine Frage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drohnen?
Oh, nee, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie das geschrieben wird.
Ja, alles klar.
Sind Sie geimpft, so wie gebostet, gegen Covid-19?
Covid-19, ja, genau, habe ich mitgemacht.
Aber trotzdem wissen Sie, vor drei Monaten war ich trotzdem bekannt an dem Virus.
Wie viel Mal?
Ich wurde dreimal geimpft und...
Dreimal geimpft und war trotzdem vor drei Monaten erkannt.
Aber das war nicht schlimm, das war vier, fünf Tage weich im Bett.
Hatte sowieso eine starke Erkältung gehabt und jetzt geht es wieder.
Oder danach ging es wieder.
Vor drei Monaten, ja?
Ja, vor drei Monaten war das, ja.
Alles klar.
Gibt es in Ihrem Familie wichtige Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel bei Ihrem Vater oder bei Mutter.
Sind Sie noch am Leben?
Meinem Vater ist verstorben, an Herzenfahrt vor einigen Jahren.
Und meine Mutter, die hat Bluthochdruckerkrankung
und die hat der Menserkrankung.
Und die lebt noch.
Die lebt im Alter zu Hause, weil es sehr schwierig war, sie zu führen.
Der Mensch ist schwer, oder?
Ja.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister, ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Ein Bruder, ist er gesund?
Ja, bis auf eine Schuppenfläche, ist er gesund.
Und wie wohnen Sie?
Wie, wie wohn ich in einer Wohnung, oder was meinen Sie?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, genau.
Ich bin verheiratet, habe zwei Kinder.
Zwei Kinder.
Aber ich wohne mit meiner Frau.
Meine Kinder sind nicht mehr in der Wohnung.
Ja, aber mit ihr Frau.
Und ich bin auch in der Wohnung.
Was sind Sie von der Hof?
Ich bin ein Einzelhandelsverkäufer.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Stress, früher habe ich Stress gehabt, aber jetzt arbeite ich einfach meiner,
lasse mir nichts viel sagen.
Ich mache einfach meine Arbeit und dann habe ich keinen Stress.
Mein Chef hatte mal Stress, ich nicht.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau, ne?
Ja, genau, ich lebe mit meiner Frau, das ist Bruder, mit ihr zusammen.
Ja.
Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport, oder?
Sie sind aktiv?
Ich würde sagen nein.
Ich fahre mit meiner Frau auf Fahrrad, aber das ist nicht regelmäßig.
Also ich bezweifle keine Arbeit.
Klar.
Und Herr Meyer, Sie haben wir unser Gespräch beendet.
Erstmal werde ich bei Ihnen körperlich untersuchen.
Danach machen wir einige weitere Untersuchungen.
Um die Krankheit festzustellen, dass sie so wie ein, es könnte ein Knochenbruch sein.
Deswegen wäre besser, wenn Sie hier etwas bleiben.
Vielleicht machen wir, ja.
Erstmal machen wir Untersuchungen.
Danach die Situation sehen wir, ob etwas passiert.
Okay.
Was für Untersuchungen wird das auch gewünscht, oder?
Ja, erst mal werden wir...
Ich habe Sie untersuchen gesagt.
Danach werden wir ein Freund kennen, der betroffene Organe veranlassen.
Beide Arme, meine Beidearme, oder eine Handgelenke?
Beide Arme sammelt wie besser beurteilen, ob ein chronische oder Veränderungen gibt.
Aber mein linker Arm tut doch nicht weh.
Ja, ich weiß.
Aber wie wissen besser, ob es alterentsprechend Veränderung oder etwas krankhaft ist?
Ist die Röntgenuntersuchung gefährlich?
Es behaltet, ja.
Ich kann sagen, dass es etwas Strahlung behaltet, aber das ist zu niedrig.
Damit Sie machen keine Sorgen dafür.
Okay.
Könnte etwas sehr Schlimmes passieren, auch wenn das Mietweg ist, auch wenn das Risiko Mietweg ist?
Was könnte das Schlimmste passieren, was sein könnte?
Sie haben das Richtige gemacht, indem Sie hier ins Krankenhaus gekommen sind.
Ich gehe einen Verdacht auf Reichtheilverletzung, aber wir müssen auch daran denken, dass es ein Knochen...
Ich habe Sie verstanden, aber nicht, warum auf einer gesunden Seite habe ich mich verstanden.
Ich habe da keinen Schmerz, warum soll ich das öffnen?
Das habe ich verstanden.
Ja, wegen zum Vergleich machen.
Okay.
Haben Sie nur Fragen an mich?
Nein, die Fragen habe ich schon gestellt.
Danke schön.
Ich werde mit meinen Kollegen sprechen und Sie körperlich alles verstanden.
Kann ich dann mit dem Oberarzt auch sprechen?
Wie bitte?
Könne ich dann mit dem Oberarzt auch sprechen?
Mit wem möchten Sie sprechen?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie werden das in dem Fall mit dem Oberarzt besprechen.
Kann ich auch mit dem Oberarzt sprechen?
Wir haben hier viele Patienten und wir arbeiten als ein Team.
Wir machen am besten für Sie.
Sie sind in Wuttenhennen.
Danke schön.
Hallo Herr Maya, ich bin Oberarzt.
Ich glaube, unser Kollege, Yusuf, hat für Aufregung vergessen, ein paar Fragen zu stellen.
Ich möchte gerne ein paar Fragen stellen.
Ich bin 1,73 m groß und wiegt 82 kg.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie Taupout und Schwach in Ihren Händen?
Nein, ich habe nicht mehr.
Ich habe nicht mehr.
Haben Sie Taupout und Schwach in Ihren Händen?
Aber ich habe Bewegung, Einstreckung und Schmerzen.
Hatten Sie jemals eine Defokumität in Ihren Hand gelenkt,
nachdem Sie ausgerüst und gestürzt waren?
Ja, ein bisschen geschwollt.
Es sieht nicht so aus, dass es abgekippt ist.
Aber es ist halt geschwollen.
Wenn ich dort berühre, wo das geschwollen ist, dann ist auch weh.
Kannst du mir sagen, ich kann meine Finger bewegen?
Ja, ich kann meine Finger bewegen, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe mich auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, von 0 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht.
Und sie sind ja schon nicht mehr so.
Also wenn ich nichts mache, dann habe ich, würde ich sagen, 3.
Und wenn ich mich meinen Handgelenk bewegen möchte, oder meinen Arm bewege,
dann tut es am Handgelenk so 7 weh, ungefähr.
Bei Belastung 7.
Vielen Dank.
Wie schnell möglich werden wir eine Röntgenaufnahme veranlassen, Herr Mayer.
Bitte machen Sie mich keine Sorgen.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Oh, so sind wir mit vielen Kollegen unterwegs, sehe ich.
Ja, wir sind ein guter Team, 25 Team jetzt momentan.
Das ist wie im Fernsehen, wenn eine Chefvisite läuft bei einem Fernseher,
wie in der Schwarzwaldklinik.
Als als Gecipit, Anfang.
Was ist es, minuten bitte?
Burüşi Mersin, warum fragt Dr. Sena Burüşi Mersin?
Er ist nicht auf die Körperregionen oder Körperteile gestürzt.
Nur rechte Handgelenke.
Hallo Herr Doktor, hatten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, Sie sind eine neue Kollege hier auf der Klinik.
Ja, heute ist mein erster Tag.
Ich würde euch Hallo sagen mit einem Patienten.
Okay, dann schießen Sie mal los, bitte.
Ja, fast.
Herr Marfred Mayer, 60-jährige Patient,
hat sich heute mit einer, er ist heute Morgen,
über ihr rechte Handgelenk gestürzt und ausgerüstet.
Der Patient klappt über Schmerzen
und in betroffene Tumor.
Auf einer Schmerzskala?
Ich würde dort nicht Tumor sagen, sondern eine Schwellung.
Man muss nicht alles einzeln, wir müssen nicht Lateinisch sprechen miteinander.
In der Realität sagt man auch, ja, über dem kann man auch sagen, aber Schwellung.
Reicht, also in der Realität sagt man auch, er hatte eine lokale Schwellung.
Weil ein Tumor ist immer so ein Begriff, ein guter, destrischer Tumor und so weiter.
Okay, bitte schön, legen Sie vor.
Ja, er hat auch Schwellung, betroffene Seite.
Die Schmerzen sind im Ruhe, 3, von 6 und bei Bewegung 7 auf eine Schmerzskala.
Die Frage nach Krebeln oder Farbeänderung, Blutung wurde vereint.
Er klappt über auch eine geschränkte Bewegung auf der betroffene Seite.
Welche Seite ist noch einmal betroffen?
Rechte Handgelenk.
Okay, danke.
Und das war hier sein Beschwerden.
Vegetativ Anamnäs ist unauffällig und hat hohe Krankungen.
Und vor Erkrankungen, er hatte jährlich Petronie seit sieben Jahren.
Und Appendectomie, also im Alter von 15, es war komplikationslos.
Er hatte auch vor 3 Monaten Covid-19 und ohne Beschwerden genessen.
Er nehme regelmäßig ACE-Inhibiteur, 10 mg, einmal morgens,
er rauche 10 Zigarette täglich seit 15 Jahren.
Ich habe es akustisch nicht gehört, Entschuldigung.
Er rauche 10 Zigaretten seit 15 Jahren.
Er trinkt ab und zu Bier, Drogen, Konsum, wo er vereint.
Er ist 3-mal gegen Covid-Geimpft.
Er ist in der Familie Anamnese.
Sein Vater ist in Myokat gestorben.
Mutter noch am Leben und leider an Demenz und Arteerli Petronie.
Er war ein Bruder, schuppenflechte.
Er ist verheiratet und hat 2 Kinder, lebt mit seiner Frau.
Er ist Verkaufer und kaum Stress in der Arbeit.
Er treibe nicht regelmäßig Sport.
Er ist ein Radiosfraktur.
Er ist ein Fraktur.
Wie sagen Sie die Diagnose?
Wenn es nicht gebrochen ist, ist es eine Disturztrauma.
Handgelenkstdisturzion wäre eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Eine Handgelenksprälung wäre eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Um meinen Verdacht zu bestätigen,
empfehle ich körperliche Untersuchung.
Danach räumt gern der rechte Handgelenk.
Ellenbogen in 2 Ebenen, mindestens.
Er hat Beschwerden im Torachsbereich.
Er hat Beschwerden im Ellenbogenbereich.
Er hat in der Gruppe eine Frage.
Er hat einen anderen Fragen.
Er hat jemand geschrieben, was ist, in der Gesellschaft,
also Schöpfung gesagt.
Ich komme in der Gesellschaft, toplum.
Ich komme in der Gesellschaft, in der Gesellschaft.
Ich mag die Gesellschaft.
Soziale Gesellschaft?
Genau.
Noch weitere Fragen?
Nicht?
Okay.